2 euh pour le moment on va parler de
cette enquête sur les délincants qui
frappent à nos portes retour sur enquête
exclusive hier soir sur M6 arnaque à
domicile les chiffres sont
impressionnants 8 millions de personnes
ont été arnaqué chez eux l'année
dernière Gill je sais que notamment pour
les fringues ce que j'ai vu cette année
à mon avis ils ont dû venir souv chez
toi faux prince charmant plombier
serruier faux postier les arnaques sont
nombreuses ce soir achelé victime d'un
faux prince charmon ah oui elle va être
avec nous pour en parler elle a perdu
plus de 30000 € à cause d'un homme ah
mince et ouais et ouais et ouais et
ouais on regarde quelques extraits et je
vous donnerai ensuite quelques conseils
afin d'éviter au mieux ces arnaques
regardez le séducteur profite d'une
occasion en or pour enfin franchir le
portail Icham est réquisitionné pour une
mission
dépana alors là ici on avait un problème
de lavabo donc c'est comme ça qu'il est
venu ici B la première fois en regardant
maintenant avec du recul je oui on a
fait j'ai fait rentrer avec le diable à
la maison il a pas d' 3 mois HM ahely
euh merci d'être là euh tu as été
victime d'info pr charmement on avoir
d'autres vidéos dans un instant euh
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec lui alors
du coup c'est une personne que je
connaissais déjà ouais euh de mon
entourage donc depuis une dizaine
d'années il s'est rapproché de moi
euh resté souvent dans la rue où
j'habitais et m' costé au début c'était
amical pendant de TR mois c'était amical
et puis il insisté pour avoir une
relation amoureuse avec moi il a insisté
oui il me disait viens on viens on
essaye de se mettre ensemble tu te
laisses pas ta chance ça faisait 2 ans
que j'étais célibataire après la
séparation avec le père de ma fille et
donc il a insisté dessus enfin tu te
laisses pas ta chance pourquoi enfin tu
restes toute seule enfin voilà a essayé
de de jouer toutes ces cartes et puis
par la suite donc il il est resté chez
vous pendant combien de temps euh devant
chez vous devant chez moi enfin ça a
duré des des mois enfin il venait euh il
avait un camion
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour vous détendre pour vous
détendre bien sûr non absolument pas
c'est-à-d que voilà il envoie un message
je suis devant chez toi passe me faire
un petit coucou rapidement je je suis en
train de m'occuper de ma fille non mais
je suis là ça dure juste 2 minutes donc
je sortais il me saluis mais 5 minutes
et puis il sortavoir contact pH le mec
était cool quoi au début il était cool
après comme je vous ai dit c'était pas
un inconnu c'estit quelqu'un
ouais de l'entourage quand on vois un
homme déterminé comme ça ça flatte aussi
ça flat mais non ça c'est c'était pas un
in G g avec
Fatou c'était où elle se mettait avec
lui où elle appelait la mariechaussée
hein je dire voilà elle a choisi tu vois
donc non non mais et donc toi vous êtes
mis en couple après on s'est mis en
couple mais il est venu habiter chez toi
non du tout parce que moi je
actuellement je vis chez ma mère
d'accord et céit un prince charmant au
début he tu avais rien à lui reprocher
un prince charmant
un prince de lu quoi au
départ non un un prince quoi B c'està-d
que c'était une personne qui a essayé
d'être là non il vené au resto il t'
acheté plein de trucs voilà donc il a oh
il faisait le taf mais s servit de ma
vie personnelle en fait pour enfin de
mon passé pour me dire je sais que tu as
vécu des histoires compliquées moi je
suis pas comme ça
je la bienveillance il était toujours
dans la
bienveillance au début il paraissait
comme une personne lambda quoi en fait
normal et alors après plusieurs mois de
relation il t'a demandé ton ton
empreunte bancaire afin de louer une
voiture euh alors ça pas commencer
directement comme ça carte bleue d'abord
non carte bleue donc rapidement en fait
je vois que j'ai des des paiement
frauduleux sur mon compte bancaire donc
quand je vois ça enfin c'était des
petites sommes beur et burit donc
j'étais amenée à changer de carte bleue
faire opposition et cetera donc c'était
10 15 € puis ensuite il m'a demandé une
première location de voiture après un
mois de relation à mon amouruse ouais
tuta es amoureuse ou pas toi bah à un
moment donné j'ai cru ouais mais quand
j'ai vu tout le mal c'est pas de l'amour
ça donc j'ai donc il voulait louer une
voiture avec
ton sur ton compte quoi non enfin
c'était il me en fait il insistait il me
dit c'est pour de jours je suis dans en
galère je dois faire je sais plus ce que
il avait à faire mais je suis en galère
c'est juste pour de jours s'il te plaît
s'il te plaît s'il te plaît au début
j'avais dit non puis ensuite enfin j'aié
les bras je me suis dit bon pourquoi pas
donc cette location de voiture il m'a
dit qu'elle sera pas débité sur mon
compte te mais première chose qu'il fait
il court après moi il me dit voilà je
rends la voiture plutôt que prévu mais
elle va avoir un débit sur ton compte
j'ai dit je peux pas me permett je va
être à découvert donc ce qu'il a fait a
récupéré ma carte bleue il a déposé les
sour sur mon compte il m'a dit tu vois
je suis une personne de confiance je
peux me faire confiance donc voilà donc
c'est un habitué voilà c'est ça donc don
pour ça t'a coûté combien d'argent cette
histoire avec ce gars là au total plus
de 38000 € 38000 € ouais et les factures
sont arrivées après pr il a fait
quoiou et c'est les factures sont
arrivées après il a fait quoi avec
l'oseille ouis alors avec l'argent ben
c'estàd qu'il a le jour de
l'anniversaire de ma fille il avait volé
ma carte bleue il était parti dans un
magasin donc Intermarché et un tabac
donc 500 € en tabac 100 200 € à peu près
en Intermarché pour faire des courses je
me rends compte de ça le lendemain donc
je le pointe du doigt je lu dis enfin
comment c'est possiblefin ce jour-là je
sais que je l'ai vu mais je l'ai pas
donné ma carte bleue ouais come
excuse-moi est-ce que tu penses que vous
étiez plusieurs sur la liste comme
l'arnaqueur de tinder qui avait eu
plusieurs F et qui servait de ton argent
pour flatter les autres et les avoir ai
dans le il a loué il a loué pour 27000 €
de voiture le gars oui il a loué quoi
des grosses voiture c'est un prince aprs
en fait j'étais pas au courant de tout
c'est-à-dire que y a il y a eu des des
durées auqueles je ne savais pas des
contrats dans mon dos il a des vols de
papier dans mon dos c'estàd que pendant
que j'allais aux toilettes et cetera il
prenaent je pense ma carte d'identité en
photo carte bleue parce qu'il a aussi il
surpay mon identité et c'est j'ai je me
suis rendu compte dans des magasins qui
avait des des lignes ouvertes à mon nom
alors que moi enfin je n'ai aucune ligne
ouverte à à mon nom plus tu as été
remboursé ou pas non pas du tout mes
plaines sont pas traités jusqu'à ce000
boules alors on il assume PL pleinement
ses arnaques hein puisque selon lui il
s'agit d'un moyen de gagner sa vie
regardez sais que j'ai fait pas mal de
trucs tu es au courant que je me suis
pas arrêté oui tu es pas en prison pour
l'instant parce qu'ils savent pas tout
ce que tu as fait ils sont ils sont en
train de chercher au jour d'aujourd'hui
je suis cramé tu sais que tu brises des
confiances tu brises des cœurs non je
suis quo c'est la façon de faire de
l'argent on va dire en quelque sorte
cert c'est pas bon c'est pas la bon
c'est pas le bon côté c'est pas le bon
truc pour toutes les escroqueries dont
il est accusé Icham le prédateur
multirécidiviste en cours jusqu'à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et ouais et ouais mais
bon est-ce que tu vas te rembourser
toi j'ai l'Impr d' d'être abandonné par
la justice a quoi ils t'ont dit quoi bah
rien
il traitent pas mon dossier vous avez un
avocat non alors quand j'ai contacté à
deux reprises donc deux avocats
différents la réponse c'est tant qu'il
n'est pas arrêté euh c'est un peu jouer
au chat et la souris c'est-à- direire
que ça ne sert à rien d'avoir un avocat
tant qu'il n'est pas arrêté ah d'accord
oui d'c vous avezpé plaines j'ai six
plaintes contre lui si si plaines merci
alors il y a Ahel tuit pas la seule à
Têtre faernaquer par ce par ce gars
puisque camille a perdu aussi 5000 € à
cause de cet homme qu'elle a voulu aider
regardz il m'a demandé que je puisse
l'aider pour qu'il puisse recevoir son
salaire sur mon compte l'individu fonce
à la banque déposer un chèque volet
d'une valeur de 4000 € sur le compte de
la jeune femme le soir même la mère de
famille constate l'opération elle croit
que c'est le salaire d'icham versé par
son patron en fait c'est le chèque volé
ce subterfuge va permettre à ISAM
d'encaisser l'argent et de laisser
l'ardoise à
Camille soir même il a insisté pour que
je puisse lui faire un un vir les 4000 €
en poche il abandonne la jeune femme et
prend la fuite vers Paris e ouais eh
c'est fou par là Camille oui ouais vous
êtes vous avez fait un collectif on a
fait un collectif elle m'a retrouvé
parce que le compte bancaire qu'il a
utilisé il a mon nom et que je peux rien
faire pour le fermer c'est un compte
nickel je peux pas quand j'essaie de
contacter le on m'arrête on peut rien
faire parce que j'ai pas l'identifiant
du compte qui se trouve sur le la carte
com ca faire euh qu'il a qui dispose de
ce compte bancaire ouais depuis euh à
peu près juillet-août 2022 d'accord ah
ouais donc toi là financièrement comment
tu fais comment je fais bah je survis là
j'ai passé j'essaie de passer à autre
chose j'ai une fille donc j'essaie de
faire en sorte qu'elle a elle mieux déjà
de rien laisser paraître et euh et voilà
après je il y a un moment donné où j'ai
travaillé du lingi au dimanche
c'estàdire que j'ai mon métier tu fais
quoi dans la vie je suis secrétaire
médical j'ai perdu mon emploi par
rapport à cette histoire parce que ça
m'a rapporté des problèmes de santé donc
ta kikardi Haos de tension et cetera
donc j'ai dû m'arrêter et à mon retour
au travail on m'a proposé une rupture
conventionnelle parce que ce modo Montat
de santé nit plus possible pour eux
voilà donc trouvé l'amour ou pas
l'amour je le cherche pas tellement mais
tu sais l'amour il faut pas le chercher
il frappe à ta porte bon
ouais a je m'en sortais déjà mieux seul
en fait concrètement ouais tuas envie de
rester seul ouais non si je trouve
quelqu'un il faut qu'il soit égal à moi
pas en dessous de moi ouais ça c'est pas
possible ouais donc là pour l'instant
j'y pense pas trop jeou tu es pas sur tu
es pas sur pas làdessus non alors il y a